What we're trying to do in the laboratory
is to simulate a process that we think was
very common on the early Earth.
And it's still common today, in fact.
Whenever ran falls on a volcano, it makes
little puddles that are heated by the volcanic
energy.
When it stops raining, those puddles evaporate.
So we have a wet-dry cycle occurring all the
time on volcanic areas of the present-day
Earth.
In the laboratory, we are simulating that
by building a chamber.
The chamber has got to be anaerobic, meaning
there can't be any air in it, because the
oxygen in today's chamber — in today's atmosphere
— will damage the chemicals that we're trying
to work with.
So we are loading this chamber up with an
inert gas.
It happens to be carbon dioxide, but we could
use something like nitrogen if we wanted to.
Carbon dioxide is easy to use.
We have a tank sort of blowing CO2 sort of
into the chamber.
And as the CO2 comes into contact with the
reaction medium that we are testing, it dries
it out.
We have the equivalent of volcanic heat.
We have two heaters under a big disk, an aluminum
disk, that is turning very slowly.
And every vial that is embedded in this disk,
there's 24 of them, goes through one wet-dry
cycle every 90 minutes.
So that's how we're simulating it.
We're drying it out under a stream of carbon
dioxide.
We're rehydrating with just plain old water.
Then it goes through another drying cycle.
This occurs every 90 minute.
And in a typical experiment we'll have about
four of these cycles in a day that we will
then analyze the result and see what we've
made, if anything.